on va parler aujourd'hui du nouvel
iphone qui doit-on calque pas acquis ici
dans ma poche l'iphone 11,1 des nouveaux
smartphones de cette année alors d'ici
quelques jours on va parler du iphone
onze pros max mais bon je vous invite à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
comme ça vous saurez tout comprendre par
là dans quelques jours
j'ai voulu commencer par celui là j'ai
pris un peu mon temps histoire de bien
bien bien le connaître de frémont de
faire peur avec lui et au final cet
iphone 11 est vraiment intéressant sur
trois points essentiels il ya trois
nouveautés sinon c'est exactement la
même chose que l'iphone 10r de l'année
dernière
permettez moi de vous présenter ces
trois points vous avez effectivement la
puce la batterie et l'appareil photo
au delà de ça c'est la même chose mais
attention est ce que ça vaut le coup est
ce que cet iphone 11 est intéressant est
ce qu'il faut l'acheter qu'est ce que
ces trois nouveaux points apporte
réellement par rapport aux bonnettes de
l'année dernière et au final est-ce que
l'iphone et l'iphone qu'il faut acheter
cette année oui ou non
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce qui fait la force d'apple
c'est plus temps l'innovation esthétique
en disant tiens j'ai nouvel écran qui
n'a pas dans koch tiens j'ai le nouveau
truc qui vraiment bord à bord saget le
nouveau truc qui donc point de vue
esthétique révolutionnaire dont là
dessus très clairement apple est à la
bourre apple est ce qu'ils sont reposés
sur nos lauriers je ne pense pas je
pense qu'ils sont fait devancer par
android parce qu'il ya une vraie grosse
différence vous avez effectivement apple
ios d'un côté et vous avez android de
tous les concurrents qui sont notre côté
et la grosse différence ça se joue bien
évidemment par l' os mais du coup apple
lui de son côté la joue un peu à part
banda pas c'est une stratégie qui est
plutôt gagnante est assez intéressante
même si effectivement vu la concurrence
vu l'offre et vous proposeront fera du
côté de chez android ça devient
difficile pour apple mais néanmoins pour
tous ceux qui aiment eyeos qui
succombent justement à la force de
frappe d'apple c'est à dire avoir un
écosystème complet cohérent avec des
machines qui fonctionne parfaitement
bien ensemble et ça extrêmement
facilement c'est très flou très simple
vous ayez une apple watch que vous ayez
un iphone vous ayez un mac vous ayez ce
que vous voulez d'apple chez vous tout
fonctionne parfaitement maintenance en
blanc il ya des domaines sur lesquels
apple est moins performant aujourd'hui
comment ça arrive est un petit peu à la
bourre mais apple continue à progresser
à être sur le marché puis collé sur leur
force de frappe
j'imagine qu'ils peuvent en tout cas
rattraper leur retard alors on se
concentre aujourd'hui que sur le device
c'est vrai quand on regarde comme ça cet
iphone et bien il a rien de
révolutionnaire il ressemble trait pour
trait à l'iphone que vous avez l'année
dernière on a le même châssis en
aluminium
on a le même écran on a quasiment le
même design si ce n'est à l'arrière
la nouveauté vient effectivement l'aria
vous êtes toujours un dos en verre pour
pouvoir permettre la recharge à
induction bien vous avez une partie qui
est un peu matin au niveau du module
photo c'est vraiment une nouveauté qui a
porté dans ce modèle la double module
photo vous avez cette petite partie qui
est légèrement plus mates qui apportent
quelque chose de différent avec un petit
relief qui est différent sion le logo
qui est situé au centre c'est pas mal ça
je trouve que c'est un peu différent où
des dj mais pas trop ce système lorsque
j'en avais entendu parler en tout cas
sur le côté mais au final je trouve que
c'est assez bien intégré m'ont aussi
habitués y aussi probablement de ça donc
ça c'est plutôt intéressant mais au-delà
de ça voyez on a exactement le même
modèle vous avez ici votre bouton
tiroirs de cartes sim même haut parleurs
même port light
vous avez exactement le même souci même
bouton ce smartphone est exactement le
même que l'iphone 10r de l'année
dernière donc c'est vrai que d'un point
de vue purement design apple est à la
bourre mais je pense que il cherche pas
particulièrement à être dans cette
course de design est dans cette course
de l'iphone avec un écran plainte sans
en poche
c'est d'ailleurs un peu dommage parce
que je trouve qu'au final c'est un coach
elle donne un look un petit peu
vieillissant iphone alors qu'on voit des
smartphones sur android qui n'ont plus
d'encoches ont des petites bulles monde
et petites encoches légère vers le haut
c'est quand même un peu dommage alors un
côté de ça ils ont la technologie flex
heidi fleiss heidi demande effectivement
avoir la place et tant qu'ils seront pas
capables d'intégrer cette techno fait
saïdi parfaitement bien
sous l'écran pour qu'elles deviennent
invisibles eh bien on va manger cinq
grandes en cauchies appelé au risque de
la manger pendant longtemps parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que apple va
intégrer une techno parce qu'ils la
maîtrisent rond parfaitement bien de a à
z donc lorsqu'elle sera vraiment
éprouver donc lorsque vous aurez déjà vu
probablement depuis quelques années à
quelque chose près chez les concurrents
chez android donc c'est vrai que c'est
toujours un petit peu regrettable se
retrouver avec cette grande entre chaque
prouve qu'aujourd'hui fin 2019
ça c'est pas très très beau vous avez
quand même des bords qui sont assez
proéminent par rapport à ce qu'on peut
retrouver laurent et sur un iphone onze
ans maintenant
quelles sont les différences
significatives qu'est ce que ça peut
nous apporter réellement pourquoi est ce
qu'il faudrait acheter potentiellement
stephen j je vous disais c'est
exactement le même produit 194 g ça n'a
pas changé mais manque auch même
ergonomie prise en main qui reste
vraiment excellente et toujours un écran
lcd 6,1 pouces de diagonale 1792 par 828
peaks est un petit peu bâtard à 326
pixels par pouce
la qualité par contre de l'écran même si
on se dit on est sur du lcd et bien
croyez moi la qualité de l'écran elle
est complètement bleus chante lorsque
vous regardez comme ça il vous mettez à
côté un iphone 11 promax et on sera pas
tout de suite compte de la différence
on s'en rend vraiment compte lorsqu'on
arrive sur les contrastes et lorsqu'on
arrive sur les noirs c'est une dalle qui
est extrêmement bien maîtrisée
extrêmement bluffante pourvoir pour les
sourds du lcd la qualité est dingue les
couleurs sont vraiment beaux la
luminosité est excellente le duo ci est
vraiment cool vous avez des hauts
parleurs stéréo premier haut parleurs
qui situe son côté les deuxièmes haut
parleurs qui est ici pour ma part sauf
et l'audio marche très très bien
vraiment du fond est plutôt bien on n'a
donc pas la voyons peu bloqué là le haut
parleur là ça marche bien on a une bonne
qualité sonore alors effectivement on
n'a pas la même direction du sol qui va
arriver entre la et la met à tout et ça
c'est cool
par contre ce que je reproche lorsque
j'utilise ce smartphone comme ça c'est
une fois de plus vous voyez cette grande
encoches qui est là je trouve que ça
devient aujourd'hui comme je le disais
en 2019 à services gracieux d'un
diablement ja du contenu c'est pas
terrible oui la même manière sur pozzi
ça vient de manger des choses à bien
manger les caractères s'ils veulent
manger un bout de l'île ici ça vient de
manger des informations de jean ba voila
je trouve que ça c'est un des points de
regrets en tout cas sur cet iphone la
voyez c'est pareil ici le bouton pour
m'aider coup de poing est à moitié mangé
ici niveau de l'encoche voilà ça c'est
un point de regret alors est ce qu'on
vous dit ça l'éditeur de venir améliorer
ce point peut-être mais c'est vrai en
tout cas que cet iphone pour ça n'est
pas optimale après il ya un poste auquel
il est vraiment optimale c'est la puce à
13 bionic qui lui confère la fluidité de
la puissance et qui va lui racheter
encore plus de l'endurance au niveau de
l'autonomie sympa qui étaient améliorées
effectivement cette année c'est la
batterie on a eu plus grosse batterie
par rapport à ce qu'on pouvait en mai
dernier à votre vie plus grosse batterie
le tour des guillemets chez apple
parce que pour apple c'est pas la taille
qui compte c'est pas le nom qui compte
c'est l'optimisation logicielle essais
des forces de frappe en tout cas si vous
voulez d'apple c'est de se dire nous on
a quelque chose qui est extrêmement
maîtrisé de a à z
on a nos propres puces on en os qui est
extrêmement maîtrisé c'est notre donc on
le maîtrise et on a pris tout de manière
à ce que tout fonctionne
merveilleusement bien ensemble ce qui
fait qu ici on n'a pas une batterie de 4
mille milliards on et batterie de 3110
millan période quand même plus grosse
que la batterie que vous aviez l'année
dernière et lors le fait d'abord cette
nouvelle batterie un peu plus grosses
avec surtout la puce à 13 bionique vous
confère vraiment quelque chose qui va
marcher qu'il est surtout extrêmement
ans durant à peu nous annoncer une heure
de plus d'autonomie par rapport à ce
qu'on peut avoir sur l'iphone 10r de
l'année dernière alors c'est compliqué à
quantifier cette maniable ça dépend
effectivement des visages lui croyez moi
l'autonomie est excellente vous pouvez
le garder un jour et demi deux jours
salée pendant vos usages une bonne
journée en tout cas
si vous avez un usage intensif et ça
c'est vraiment bien pour par contre le
chargeur vous avez à l'intérieur et pas
complètement dingue
il faut sa retraite elle est compatible
recharge 18 watts par contre ça il
faudra les acheter en plus ça fonctionne
comme ça chez apple
vous pouvez par contre toujours venir
recharger son fils à l'induction ce que
vous le posez donc à droite les peuples
je suis là je ne pose je pars je leur
charge après vote à gauche ça c'est
pratique et même fait ça il dit va être
un peu plus rapide un peu plus
performants pop
je venais en face ça marche ça des deux
roues très très vite parce que vous avez
effectivement c'est plus
a13 bionique qui va être meilleur en
calcul pour l'autonomie pour la rapidité
la fuite et pour le gaming pour tout ce
que vous voulez donc c'est vrai que pour
jouer à différents types de jeu ici
comme strates neuf ça marche bien une
fois de plus va regretter cette en
cochant le côté mais bon ça c'est l'adn
de ce produit il est comme ça à côté de
ça c'est fluide ça roule ça marche
d'ailleurs ça roulait plutôt bien sur
asphalte neuf donc ça c'est assez cool
l'eau est ce qu'on va voir là dessus
c'est eyeos 13 qui toujours plus fluide
plus optimisée qui marche bien qu'ils
pratiquent fait comme je vous le disais
pas partie de cet écosystème apple qui
permet que tous les appareils apple
fonctionne ensemble donc l'expérience
ayo si vous aimez effectivement usa rios
13 c'est sûr maîtriser ça marche très
bien mais là où cet iphone prend toute
son ampleur et devient vraiment
intéressant que c'est l'expérience au
niveau de la photo et de la vidéo qui
s'est amélioré on retrouve pour la
première année sans les fautes premier
palier de caméra à l'arrière donc ça
c'est nouveau c'est assez intéressant
on aurait pu s'attendre à voir un tel
objectif pour avoir un zoom x 2 devient
on l'aura pas en contentera d'un zoom
numérique on va par contre avoir un
grand temps qu'une caméra normale 12
mégapixels on fonctionne toujours 12
mégapixels chez apple mais ça marche
merveilleusement bien
on a une caméra principale grand angle
équivalent 26000 les mecs qui ouvre à f
1.8 et un ultra grand-angle de 120° qui
ouvre à f 2.4 et un équivalent 13 mm sa
part contre croyez moi c'est vachement
intéressant ce qu'on peut faire avec
en termes de photos en terme de vidéo ça
apporte un gap c'est vraiment cool et
vous venez cauet derrière un os 13 avec
une expérience au niveau de l'appareil
photo qui a été amélioré
significativement améliorée et ça donne
un truc qui est vraiment bien vous avez
donc un rendu photo qui est vraiment
extrêmement qualitatif que je fais plein
de photos à new york regardez-moi ça
comme c'est vachement bien là je passe
sur l'ultra grand-angle et ce qui est
cool voyait c'est que je trouve que la
colorimétrie est la même c'est maîtrisé
c'est beau le reproche qu'on pourrait le
faire sur le très grand temps comme sur
beaucoup d'autres très grand temps que
c'est légèrement déformé pas super bien
corriger d'un point de vue logiciel et
l'immeuble à part sur légèrement sur le
côté
ici en bas c'est pareil on à l'ars on
dit ça pourrait être optimisée d'un
point de vue en tout cas purement
logicielle chaussée la colorimétrie et
très vite les photos sont très naturels
personnellement j'adore je trouve que
c'est extrêmement bien maîtrisée de la
part d'apple
la halle sur l'appareil photo principale
ultra grand angle et là on arrive sur le
joug
foi de leur zone x 2 ici en numérique
mais ça fonctionne quand même c'est
plutôt pas mal
elles seront par contre vraiment la pâte
d'apple et photos qui sont légèrement
plus jeune et mon bon voyez moi je
trouve que ça marche bien une fois de
plus je suis sûr celle là j'arrive sur
l'autre on va compter sur deux objectifs
différents
c'est extrêmement bien maîtrisé très
bien rattrapé on va quasiment pas la
différence grand angle ultra grand-angle
une fois 2e et pour voir qu'on est sur
un zoom numérique franchement on
s'habille d'un mois soit on danse bien
quand même
regardez là le ciel est juste on a bien
les détails on voit bien les lampadaires
sympa quand même assez naturel qu il ya
un beau travail qui est fait de la part
d'apple même sur l'ultra grand pont ce
qui est quand même plutôt bien alors
c'est peut-être pas le revoir les photos
nues il est plus what the fuck par
rapport à part sur impétrantes promet ça
marche quand même hyper mais
regardez-moi salle on a tous les détails
on à la lampe
on a les lumières c'est juste on a bien
l'ambiance de la ville surtout ça qui
est le plus important en captant un peu
moins lumière forcément à coutras grand
temps pareil ici en vigueur que dans une
scène à l'intérieur ça marche luttera
grand-angle ça fait son petit effet même
si c'est tout de suite beaucoup moins
précis beaucoup moins bien c'était pas
là on aura le meilleur design le plus
beau design qu'on pourra retrouver par
rapport à ce qui existe si elle marchait
en tout cas à la concurrence chez
android c'est une certitude pour moi le
design il commence un peu à être des
whites un peu le regret que je vais
avoir tout on arrive sur un produit qui
coûte quand même 809 euros sur le 64
gigaoctets de stockage
voilà ça c'est un petit peu dommage par
contre tous cas l'intérieur marche très
bien la puce à 13 bionique qui est la
nouveauté cette année est merveilleuse
marche parfaitement bien ça vous le
classe dans les smartphones les plus
performants l'autonomie est excellent
l'appareil photo est excellent pour moi
c'est un excellent smartphone il ya
l'autre point sur lequel apple est
excellent il progresse toujours plus et
sur la vidéo la qualité je la trouve
vraiment très très juste
lo'jo est cool car tu peux bien l'auto
et surtout c'est la stabilisation vous
avez une stabilisation qui est
complètement incroyable sur la caméra
rien c'est extrêmement bien maîtrisé
c'est vraiment obsédé bouge absolument
pas il ya un autre truc qui est vraiment
bien
une expérience c'est que lorsque vous
avez filmé comme ça avec votre
smartphone venir zoomer dézoomer
directement vous gardez la stabilisation
dans le secteur des jeux lire zoom et je
crois à gauche assure la voiture de
police avec le zoom numérique à tous a
encore bien du numérique
je n'ai regardé la stabilisation est
incroyable c'est il ya vraiment un
excellent boulot a été fait de la part
d'apple là dessus je le dis je le redis
une fois de plus pour moi en tout cas en
terme de vidéo
je pense que c'est un des meilleurs
smartphones vidéo du marché que j'ai pu
voir pour le moment et je ne cesserai de
vous le dire un smartphone comme ça
aussi beau soit-il il faut quand même le
protéger pour éviter les déconvenues
éviter qu'on puisse le cas c'est la
limite ce tout ça tout ça c'est quand
même dommage ça sera un peu ballot une
fois de plus je vous parle de mon
partenaire green aussi parce qu ils ont
des coqs qui vont à tous vos iphone et
ça c'est vachement bien
on a donc le choix entre plein de
produits et ça croyez moi c'est
intéressant parce qu'il faut comme le
protégé alors moi ce que je trouve que
conseiller c'est d'utiliser le crash
guère d'allant crasse garde c'est
vachement cool parce que vous conservez
votre dos vous prenez votre trace garde
vous le mettez autour de ça ça vous
permet effectivement d'un de profiter de
votre dos de profiter de votre bandeau
rouge des prés rouge j'aime bien les
produits 13e c'est qu'on est nombreux à
aimer la couleur des produits très bas
sont extrêmement bien fini très bien le
fils donc ça c'est cool donc ça c'est la
première le premier point et vous avez
un deuxième point c'est la solide suite
la solitude qui est la coque qui va
venir plus le fermer le protéger il note
que tous ces malades
il ya t'il est enrhumé il ya côté vous
la prenez vous le mettez votre
smartphone dedans ça vous permet d'avoir
un smartphone protégé alors ça va
rajouter un peu en épaisseur sur les
bords mais c'est normal parce que ça
vient le protéger vous avez votre petite
caméra derrière tout est là vous avec ce
bouton ça marche donc ça c'est
intéressant
moi je vous recommande très bien
protégés et si vous voulez aller encore
plus loin bien vous avez les écrans de
protection médine windchill donc ça
c'est cool et positif partait sur la
vidéo ci voulait filmer pour filmer
jusqu'à 4/4 à 60 images par seconde
what the fuck c'est plutôt cool alors il
faut savoir ce smartphone ressemble
trait pour trait iphone discerne 10
apparaît effectivement d'un point de vue
esthétique à l'arrière sinon c'est la
même chose lorsque vous regardez comme
ça il a la même certification qui
perçoit son clip même avec rolls même
châssis le même plein de choses mais par
contre il est différent il a une
meilleure plus permis d'aller beaucoup
plus loin
meilleure autonomie et surtout en photo
ils continuent leur progression continue
à être maîtrisé et c'est ce que j'aime
beaucoup tout cas chez apple avec cet
iphone l'iphone ou alors l'iphone on se
prend max dans quelques jours qui va lui
beaucoup plus loin vous verrez c'est
encore tout autre chose mais qui est
parfaitement bien maîtrisée bien
évidemment ça vous paraît complètement
normal alors est-ce qu'il faut acheter
cet iphone là est ce qu'il vaut le coup
est-ce qu'il faut se positionner sur
l'iphone 11 de cette année eh bien je
dirais que si vous voulez un iphone si
vous voulez ce qui se fait de mieux dans
les iphone
si vous voulez un excellent photophone
de jour comme de nuit si vous voulez
quelque chose qui est performant
puissant que vous voulez surtout être
sur ios et bien pour moi l'iphone 11
c'est un excellent modèle c'est pas un
smartphone au rabais c'est vraiment un
excellent smartphone qui pourront en
tout cas vraiment vous satisfaire alors
si vous voulez vous satisfaire il ya
plusieurs prix alors l'iphone
11 lorsque vous l'achetez en 64
gigaoctets de stockage il coûte 809
euros peut toujours acheter l'iphone 10r
si effectivement vous vous en moquez
d'avoir un meilleur appareil photo si
vous en moquez de jeu de plus
performants et de mire optimisé l'iphone
issers coûte 100 euros de moins peut
donc retrouver à 709 euros si vous le
voulez celui-là à l'iphone 11
avec 128 go de stockage pour moi c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut aller mais 64 gérer
le stockage vous restiez rapidement
d'être un petit peu limite limite ça
serait vraiment dommage tout vu la bête
que vous allez avoir entre vos mains
859 euros vous rajoutez 50 euros c'est
pareil pour l'iphone 10r écoutera 759
euros
et si vous voulez vous régalez vous
faire plaisir vous l'avez en 256
gigaoctets de stockage à 979 euros pour
moi un iphone de cette année l'iphone
11 c'est un excellent produit sommes
très bon cru cette année je regrette
vraiment seul où je regrette vraiment
set en poche
j'espère que apple va réussir très
rapidement à pouvoir intégrer sa caméra
trop d'eps sous son écran ça va arriver
à les prochains sur le constructeur donc
je me demande si apple intel aura je
pense qu'apple ne l'atteindra pas
l'année prochaine parce qu'il faut du
temps pour la recherche et développement
pour que ça se mette en place pour que
les constructeurs puissent l'intégrer de
la meilleure façon dont peut-être en
2021 chapple peut-être à mon avis on va
encore manger en 2020 de l'encoche voilà
ça c'est vraiment le gros point de
regret à vous nous dire ce que vous en
pensez comment vous le prouver cet
iphone 11 vous trouvé intéressant est ce
qu'il vous plaît qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce design qui est malgré tout
vos pauvres chéris est vraiment malade
oreille et se soignerait et trier les
bons
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cet
iphone qu est ce que vous le trouvez
bien intéressant que ce que vous pensez
de ce design avec ses bords un petit peu
content surtout qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce nouveau design arrière
cette nouvelle caméra toussa toussa
toussa et surtout est-ce que vous
pourriez être tenté pour l'acheter si
c'est le cas ici vous intéresse vous
avez bien évidemment des liens en bas
dans la description avoue médias
maintenant ce que vous en pensez
quant à nous on se retrouve dès demain
est très prochainement pour parler de
l'iphone 11 promax et on parle demain à
new york
je sens que ça va envoyer du bois à des
vins tout